all right resorts world announced some
major star power in a very unique
and fabulous way today rocky theist
joining us live with a
great view and of course all the details
hey rocky
hey kirsten yeah you see that great view
right there it's playing right over
my shoulder that is the brand new first
ever commercial for resorts world and it
stars some very familiar a-list faces so
let's take a look
it's the announcement we've been waiting
for since monday okay this immersive
first of its kind short film
the first commercial filmed on a live
virtual set by the way
is called stay fabulous and it features
celine dion
carrie underwood luke bryan katy perry
tiesto
and zed suggesting all of those artists
will hit the stage at some point
at resorts world the resorts world
tagline says
stay fabulous and it is a reminder to
embrace individuality
and create your own version of fabulous
i love that
and check this out a couple of the
featured superstars were pretty quick to
respond to the video release luke bryan
says
looks like a good time and zed followed
up with let's go with a lot of
exclamation points i quote so
you can tell they're just a little
excited right
we're all a little excited for resource
world to open we've been watching it
get built right over on the north side
of the strip so it opens officially for
everybody
june 24th and you can book your tickets
now or book your rooms excuse me now or
your tickets to the show i guess i could
say
it's all great news that's a fabulous
marketing campaign as well and all those
artists are tremendous so
i like it kirsten i want to book our
cabana
oh okay don't get fancy i like it
details to come thanks rocky